N
THOUSAND STUDENTS AND HAVE BEEN
PREPARING FOR THE OPENING FOR
LAST EIGHT MONTHS. YEAH WE
BEGAN TO ON GAY THE IMPACTS OF.
OUR FIRST WHICH IN DAEGU OF
COURSE KOREA ON THE END OF
SEPTEMBER. THAT WASN'T SEVEN
TWO HOURS WE'VE SO FROM
BREAKING IN PERSON SCHOOL TO
REMOTE OF SCHOOLING FOR OUR
CHILDREN. OR ERIC FOR TO DO THE
OF THE WRONG PARTY. ALSO WERE
PREDICATED ON ALL OF THIS SO-
PLAYING REACTION IN OPENING
PREPARATIONS ARE BASED ON THE
SECRETARY SECRETARY DEFENSE
PRIORITIES WHICH IS SAFE YOU
SERVICEMEN- SERVICE MEMBERS-
DOD CIVILIANS AND FAMILY
MEMBERS ON IT ALSO BECAUSE TO
SUSTAIN COMBAT. COMBAT
CAPABILITIES. OR PRIORITIES
DIRECTOR OR MORE PRIORITIES THE
DIRECTION IS STILL SCHOOL AND
ASKED AND FOR OUR CHILDREN AND
OUR STAFF AND OUR TEACHERS ARE
WONDERFUL TEACHERS THAT SHOULD
BE ON THE CONTINUITY OF
EDUCATION. AND IT IS HIS WORK
IS IMPORTANT- THE BEST
EDUCATION IS FACE TO FACE IN A
CLASSROOM. THAT'S OUR PRIORITY
WAS TO OPEN EVERY CLASSROOM
THAT WE CAN SAFELY- AND
FLEXIBILITY BECAUSE IS A
REMARKABLE- YEAH THE SITUATIONS
THAT WE'RE FACING AROUND THE
WORLD IN THE LAST WEEK. OR
FLEXIBLE IN OUR APPROACH-
PROBABLY WON'T BE SUCCESSFUL
AND TO DATE I THINK THAT WE'VE
BEEN REMARKABLY FLEXIBLE AND
COOPERATIVE AND- COORDINATING
IN. EVERY STEP OF THE WAY
ACTUALLY. THAT'S THE- THERE'S I
HAVE I NEEDED TO TAKE A MOMENT
AND EXPLAIN SOME OF THE MODES
OF INSTRUCTION WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT- BECAUSE IS EASILY
CONFUSED BETWEEN VIRTUAL WELL
THEY'RE BOTH USING COMPUTERS
EIGHT SO IN CIRCUMSTANCES AS I
SAID BEFORE TEACHING CHILDREN
IS THE BEST WAY IS IN A
CLASSROOM WITH WITH- OF WHAT
SOME OF OUR GREAT TEACHERS SO
THAT'S THE NUMBER ONE PRIORITY
IS A SAFE WE DO THAT. NUMBER
TWO IS THAT THAT THERE ARE
CIRCUMSTANCES BECAUSE OF THE
NATURE OF THE COVID- THE END
AND THE IMPACT ON THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE CAN'T AT
THE END SO THAT THE
INSTALLATION WOULD BE AT A
CERTAIN HAVE COME UP ON THIS
CASE WOULD BE CHARLIE WE'RE
COMFORTABLE CHARLIE AND WE
CAN'T OPEN AND SO THEN WE HAVE
TO CONTINUE THAT EDUCATION
PROCESS FOR WHAT WE CALL
REMOTE. REMOTE SCHOOLING IS WE
HAVE THE CHEEK IT'S GEARED FOR
CLASSES AT A TEACHER THINK OF
IT AS THE TEACHERS TAKING A
CLASS ON THE COMPUTER TO THEIR
CHILDREN HOLDING. HANDS AND
THEY'RE ALL. AND THEY MODIFY
INTRO BASED WHAT WOULD HAVE
HAPPENED IN THE CLASS. ALL AND
IT'S WITH YOUR CLASS SWITCHER
YOU'RE SEEING AS SOON CLASSROOM
IN THE SCHOOL CLASSROOM YOU'RE
DOING A SONG. AND IT'S IN THAT
SENSE IT'S FROM BUT IT'S CLASH
ORIENTED FOR THOSE SPECIFIC
CHILDREN KNOWING THAT THEY WILL
RETURN TO A BRICK AND MORTAR
AND THEY WILL BE TOGETHER AGAIN
SO THAT'S WHAT WE CALL REMOTE
LEARNING WHERE TEACHERS GO AND
TAKE THEIR CLASSROOMS HOME.
VIRTUAL LEARNING IS DIFFERENT
WE'VE HAD A VIRTUAL SCHOOL FOR
TEN YEARS. IT WAS AIMED
PRIMARILY FOR HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS. WHO ARE IN REMOTE
LOCATIONS YOU CAN'T TAKE
VERTICAL FOR EIGHT P. CAMERA
WOULD BE DIFFICULT TO DO WE
DON'T HAVE THE STAFF AND
EQUIPMENT AT A REMOTE HIGH
SCHOOL SO THEY'RE ALLOWED TO DO
IT THROUGH THE- VIRTUAL SCHOOLS
WHERE THE CURRICULUM IS
DESIGNED FOR COMPUTERS- WE
HAVEN'T STRUCTURES TEACHERS WHO
LEAD THE PROCESS BASICALLY
STUDENT PROGRAM AS- SAID SHARON
SKETCH. AND COMPLETE THE COURSE
TWO STANDARD IN A VIRTUAL SEVEN
GEORGE DESIGN FROM START TO
FINISH IS A VIRTUAL WAR AS
REMOTE- EIGHTY EIGHT IT'S EIGHT
OH CURRICULUMS MODIFY BUT IT'S
A- THE ITSELF BRINGING THAT THE
WORKING ORDER CLASSROOM TO THE
COMPUTER AS OPPOSED TO VIRTUAL
WHICH IS DESIGNED FOR SHORT
FINISH DURBIN- FOR. THAT TYPE.
OF INSTRUCTION SO. KNOWING THAT
WITHIN OUR THREE STUDENTS AND
OUR PARENTS THAT THAT WE SHOULD
THERE WOULD BE SOME. ON
RETURNING THEIR SHOW TO WHAT WE
CONSIDER A SAFE CLASSROOMS HEY-
HAVE GONE PROBLEM. SO WHAT WE
DID WAS ABOUT THREE WEEKS AGO
WE OFFER THE OPPORTUNITY. FOR
PARENTS WHO ARE UNSURE OR NOT
COMFORTABLE SENDING OUR
CHILDREN TO OF BRICK AND MORTAR
SCHOOL SHOULD BE PARTICIPATE AT
ORIGINAL SCHOOL- ADDED THE
COMMITMENT FOR THE VIRTUAL
SCHOOLS ONE SEMESTER. AS
OPPOSED TO- HERE FOR ONE
SEMESTER- AND WE HAD ABOUT.
TWELVE HUNDRED STUDENTS IN THE
HIGH SCHOOL PORTION WHICH
EXPANDED- THE VIRTUAL SCHOOL
FROM KINDERGARTEN THROUGH HIGH
SCHOOL- AND NOW WE HAVE TEN
THOUSAND STUDENTS ENROLLED-
WE'VE OFFERED OUR TEACHERS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TEACH IN A
VIRTUAL SCHOOL- ABOUT 10%
INDICATED THAT THEY WOULD LIKE
TO DO THAT SO WILL
PROFESSIONALLY DEVELOPING THEM
AND PROVIDING THE MEDIA ON. THE
BACKGROUND AND EXPERTISE TO BE-
VIRTUAL INSTRUCTORS SO THOSE
ARE THE MODES OF OBSTRUCTION SO
WE WILL BE OPEN. IN SOME CASES
OPEN WERE CHILDREN ARE IN
CLASSROOMS WITH TEACHERS AND
SAFE ENVIRONMENT ACCORDING TO
CDC STANDARDS WE WILL HAVE
REMOTE WERE TEACHERS WILL BE
WITH THEIR CLASSROOM CLASSES
WITH THEIR WITH THEIR
CLASSMATES. AND VIRTUAL WHICH
IS DESIGNED FOR STUDENT LED
INSTRUCTOR DRIVEN- CLASSICS SO
THOSE ARE THE THREE DIFFERENT
MODES. OF INSTRUCTION. HERE ARE
SO NATIONAL. AS I SAID THE PLAN
PROCESS HAS BEEN BEGAN
SEARCHING ON AGO WELL THE GOOD
NEWS IS ONE OF LESS FROM ALL WE
WENT THROUGH WITH THE ONE
LEARNING. IN MARCH TWO THE END
OF THE YEAR ON HAND WE'VE
INCORPORATED ALL OF THOSE CDC
GUIDANCE. IRMA DEFENSE GUIDANCE
INTO OUR OPENING OF SCHOOL
EXECUTION AT THE SCHOOL LEVEL
SHORT MYSTERY RESEARCHERS ARE
AWARE OF THE SAFETY MEASURES
I'VE BEEN PUT IN PLACE- AND YOU
CAN SEE THERE IT WOULD BE IN
THE SECOND BOX THOSE ARE ALL
THE COVERT NINETEEN APARTMENTS
AND WE HAD TO. MAKE TO ENSURE
IN OUR PLANNING PROCESS. TO
PROCURE THE NECESSARY FACE MASS
AND I WAS VERY UPSET THEY
DIDN'T FACE WASHING- IN
SELECTED TULSA PLACES TO PUT
BARRIERS SO. THAT WE WILL WELL
CLAIM WE HAD EXTENDED- CRYSTAL-
CONTRACTS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT THAT IT'S GOING TO C. C.
STANDARDS- WORK WITH COMMANDERS
AND THAT'S REALLY THE KEY TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE
SCHOOLS. IS THAT WE ARE HAND IN
HAND WITH EACH ONE OF THE LOCAL
COMMANDERS AT ALL THE
FACILITIES AT ALL THE EXPERTISE
THAT THEY HAVE TO REMOVE THEIR
MEDICAL STAFF. WE DESIGN A VERY
IN DEPTH- GUIDE ON HOW TO
BOLTON SCHOOL SAFELY. THEIR
STAFF AND COMMANDERS PERSONALLY
REVIEWED IT IT WAS IMPORTANT WE
HAVE CHANGED IT ACCORDINGLY AND
NOW WE'RE IN FOR VERSION
INTRUSION TO BE VERSION THREE
AS WE UPDATE FROM THE CDC AND
THEIR LATEST GUIDANCE- AND ANY
INPUT FROM THE FIELD SO THIS
TRUE ELEMENTS ONE OF THE LOCAL
COMMANDERS. AND THEIR COMMUNITY
GET IN POLICE. I DON'T GIVE A-
LITTLE EXAM. YEAH IN THE A VERY
SHE CAN REVIEW THE PLAN FOR.
WITH THAT IS GOING TO ACTUALLY
IT AND TOLD HIM COMMANDER. THIS
IS AN AUTO YOU HOUSE. THIS IS A
BAR OPEN SCHOOL PLANNED EDISON.
OPENING OF SCHOOL AND VERY CALM
ONE HOUR EXECUTING AND I THAT
THAT KIND OF COURSE OR
COORDINATION VERY REGRETTABLE
WONDERFUL. AND NOW WE'RE IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE SUPPLY ARE ARE AT
FIELD SCHOOL THE ADMINISTRATORS
PRINCIPALS AND STAFF I ONE JOB.
IN ADDRESSING THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING THE LUNCH PROGRAMS
AND HOW THE CHILDREN WILL GET
THEM GRABBING GO ONE WHERE THEY
WILL BE WHAT SPACES WILL BE
AVAILABLE TO ENSURE THAT SMALL
TAKE CARE OF- THAT'S HARD
WORKING ORDER OPENINGS- AND I
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON OUR
OPENING BEGINS NEXT WEEKEND
SOME COURT CASES IN THE OF THE
UNITED STATES- AND THAT'S WHERE
WE'LL GO NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
THIS GIVES YOU AN OVERVIEW OF
WHAT WE'RE DOING ON THE GROUND
GREEN BECAME OUT OF THE SCHOOLS
THAT WILL BE OPEN IN BERGEN
MORGAN PERSON OR STAFF WILL
WELCOME FUTURES. WILL BE THERE
STUDENTS WILL BE THERE- THE-
YELLOW INDICATES CELLS THAT YOU
HAVE SOLUTIONS AND TOOLS WILL
BE OPEN REMOTELY AGAIN THIS IS
WHERE THE- CHILD WILL BE WITH
THEIR CLASSROOM ON A COMPUTER
AND THEN. THE VIRTUAL SCHOOL
WHICH ISN'T STRONG. WITH TEN
THOUSAND STUDENTS WILL BE
OPERATING FOR THREE TO HOLDS
FOR THE WORLD AND WE LOOK FOR
TO A ACTUALLY OPENINGS. I WOULD
SHOW THAT THERE WILL BE
SUCCESSFUL BECAUSE WE HAVE A
REMARKABLY DEDICATED STAFF OF
TEACHERS. WHO ARE ALL TEACHERS
ARE GREAT BUT OURS ARE VERY
SPECIAL BECAUSE THEY HAD THAT
EDUCATIONAL MISSION OF TAKING
CARE OF THE CHILDREN AND WOMEN.
WE PUT IN ARMS AWAY FROM
DEFENSE OF THE UNITED STATES
AND THAT'S AN ADDITIONAL MINUTE
MISSION BECAUSE WE HAVE AN
IMPACT ON READINESS. WE HAVE AN
IMPACT ON. ON RETENTION. AND SO
ON THINK THAT'S MY OVERVIEW I
THINK I CONCLUDES JULY. OPEN TO
ANYONE. OKAY WELL WE'LL GO A
LOT OF FIRST OF THE PHONES AND
I GOT YOUR ON. HAVE HAD TO TAKE
OF MS RAISING TIME TULSA SO A
LOT OF TO TALK A FEW QUESTIONS
HIM WE WANT TO MAKE SURE DICK
TAKE USE OF THIS TIME RIGHT NOW.
SO WE'LL BARBER AB. YEAH YEAH I
DON'T QUESTION GREATER YOU
BACKGROUND BUT ALSO ABOUT TO
RUN LEFT AND CAMPAIGN FLY YOU
TO ENGAGE MAYBE I DON'T KNOW
THE BREAKDOWN NUMBER YOU'VE GOT
TO IMAGINE TEN ABOUT ARMY FOR
THE GROUP'S SCHOOL THAT I MEAN
EVERYBODY ELSE'S OF THE
RETURNING TO THE- I'M A RICH
JACK'S SCHOOL IN PERSON. IT'S A
WAY WILL ALL BE RICHER JUST BUT
AS SAID BEFORE THE NEW SPEECH
OR AMONG. AN ACTUAL WORKING SO
THIS LAW THAT YOU CAN SEE I'M
SURE COULD PROVIDE IS THE
NUMBER OF SCHOOL THAT WILL BE
OPEN FACE TO FACE. FUTURE AND
OTHERS THAT WILL BE OF VIRTUAL.
SO I THINK ABOUT THE DAY IF
YOU'D LIKE TO KNOW YOU HAVE TO
GO TO GET INTO ON THE FIRST
RING ONE FOR NINETEEN OF FORTY
FIVE SCHOOL. OPERATING ONE. AND
I TO BE ABLE I WANT TO LOOK.
AND IN. ON TO SEE FOUR FOR BE
OPEN REMOTE AND THERE AND
BARBARA AND IN THE UNITED
STATES TRY FIVE OF THE THINGS
SCHOOL WILL BE ABLE REMOTELY.
BOTHERED TO INCLUDE VENDING IT
FOR ON OTHERS HELLO SO THAT'S
THE BREAKDOWN TONIGHT IS YOUR
QUESTION. SIR WELL WE'RE GOING
THREE NOT OF THOSE YOU THAT
MOST. THAT IT ACT THAT HELP YOU
WITH RIGHT NOW ON THE STUDENT.
REGIS SO THREE I THINK LIKE
EVERYBODY CHECK I DON'T HAVE A
IN FRONT OF ME BUT IT ALSO
SEVEN IS. OKAY DONALD GET BACK
TO YOU ON SERVICE IT'S OF A
NUMBER WILL BE A- IN. IN TEN
DOWN WILL BE A THE VERGE OF
SOME REMOTE WE CAN GET OUT MORE
I RIGHT DOWN TO YOU. RIGHT ONE
OF. THE TERMINOLOGY GET SOME
LARGER TOPIC QUICKLY LIKE YEAH
WE CAN DO TELL US. YOUR PHONE
NUMBER. THE DEFENSE. IS NOW.
BOTH PREPARE. AMPLE TO STEP IN.
AND PROVIDE SOME. TO SOME OF
THEM ARE. YEAH FOR ANY.
ELECTION LAST FOUR EVERY
SUPPORT FOR THE ELECTION. SO
ONE DELAY AND SO OBVIOUSLY A
ROLE WE PLAY SUPER HHS AND
SORRY DHS AND FBI RECORDS
ELECTION SECURITY SO I'LL TALK
TO FOR YOU WITH A TO THE
NATIONAL COUNTERTERRORISM
SECURITY CENTER DIRECTORS
COMMENTS ON- EFFORTS BY. ACTORS
MALIGN ACTORS- TO- FEDERAL
ELECTIONS IN OUR EFFORTS.
ALEXION SECURITY. BUT DHS. ARE
THE THIRD GOVERNMENT WE TO WITH
THEM ON. OF WILL NOT TOLERATE
INTERFERENCE FROM FOREIGN YEAH
OFFICIALS PROCESS- IN THE GIVES
OUR DEMOCRATIC INSTITUTIONS SO
WE'RE SUPPORT ROLE OBVIOUSLY-
CYBER CON AND OTHERS HAVE SOME
MORAL I'M NOT GONNA SPEAK TO
THAT BUT OVER FOR YET BEHIND
AND DHS- WITH REGARD TO THAT-
FOR THE OTHER PART OF
QUESTIONS. I WOULD JUST SAY WE
HAVE A CONSTITUTION AND- OUR
CONSTITUTION WHICH ALL MEMBERS
OF MILITARY HAVE SWORN AN OATH
TO. PROVIDE NO ROLE FOR THE US
MILITARY'S ARMORED OR POLITICAL
OR ELECTION SPEEDS- THIS ISSUE
APPEARS TO BE BORN OF UNSER
START REFLECTING A FUNDAMENTAL
LACK OF APPRECIATION FOR THE
HISTORY OF OUR DEMOCRACY. AND
THE CIVILIAN MILITARY
RELATIONSHIP ESTABLISHED UNDER
OUR CONSTITUTION. RIGHT THAT
WOULD BE JUST. THANK RIGHT WAS
TRY TO ASK YES. IS THE GOING TO
USE. DOES A ROLE. WHERE ASKED
FOR. SEVERAL LANKFORD DOES. ON
ANY OF ISSUES SO ALL. SUPPORT
TO SOME AUTHORITIES. ARE YOU.
AS YOU HAVE INCREASE SO CIVIL
WAR. OF IT VIEWERS AND- ONE.
AND WILLING. TO TAKE ON THAT
TASK FOR DO YOU. CROSS IT OFF
THE LIST OF THINGS SHE WILL NOT
GIVE WOULD YOU THREE PREPARED.
IF PASSED TO SUPPORT CIVIL
AUTHORITIES. IF THERE WAS
ELECTION POST ELECTION. UNREST
I THINK I'VE GOT A LOT MIKE MY
STATEMENT STANDS ON THAT SIDE
OF THE VEHICLE- SO WHY DON'T.
WE HAVE A HAVE A OF A COMMENT
FOR YOU ON THE ON THE
HYPOTHETICAL YOU PLAYED OUT.
THERE WITHIN THE SAME NUMBER
YOU GET A- WHAT IS JOHN UPDATE
ON AIRPORT TELECOM THAT WAS AT
A NEXT WEEK BETWEEN OVER OKAY
YEAH TO TRY DOWN SOME
INFORMATION. AND THERE'S A
INVESTOR INTO WELL WHAT TO PLAY
OBVIOUS GREATLY CAN WITH IT.
THAT WERE TAKE SHOULD. RIGHT
FIRED OF OUR AIRCRAFT WE OFF
LIKE YEAH AND YOU ASKED FORCED
OR THREE ZERO INJURY AND IT
COULD HAVE TRAGIC. OR I'M GONNA
WORK WITH THE F. AND TRY TO GET
TO THE BOTTOM OF THIS QUICKLY
AND CAMPS FOR MR BRADY YES ONE
IS IMPORTANT THAT CHILDREN GO
TO SCHOOL IN PERSON. I THINK A
LOT OF ACT AS GETTING
EDUCATORS. SAY SAY SAY. THAT
ADULT. TALENT TO TEACH
INTERFACE WITH THE TRUMP. THE
SONG CARE BETWEEN PEOPLE IN THE
CLASS. THE OF THE- TO CHANGE IT
OVER SHE TASK AS THEY OCCUR. ON
THE CORRECTIONS MAKE SURE THAT
MEETING STANDARDS. IT'S JUST
ABSOLUTELY A BETTER SITUATION
FOR US GIVEN- JEEP- ARE. THE
BEST ON THE NEXT BEST. GIVEN
THE CIRCUMSTANCES. REMOTE TRAIN
TEACHERS ORDER TO DO GO
CLASSROOM CONCERNED AND WE'VE
PRACTICE AT ALL AND WE'VE
GOTTEN BETTER THE STATISTICS
INDICATED THAT WAS REMARKABLE
SHAKY START BECAUSE ONE OF OUR
GOOGLE OF THE BY THE END OF THE
PERIOD THAT WE HAD GOING LAST
YEAR. WELL WE WERE UP 290% OF
STUDENTS WITHIN THE ON GOING TO
TWELVE FOR DAILY ON A COMPUTER-
TRAINING ASSIGNMENTS SAMA TEMEN
SIX CENTRAL SO IT WAS A
LEARNING CURVE BUT IT'S- IT'S
NOT IDEAL BUT BUT IT'S THE BEST
NEXT BEST. STUDENTS BE PLAYING
SPORTS THIS FALL. GREEN
FOOTBALL TULSA. MOVABLE OVERLY
AFTER AND ONE. WE I DID I WELL
IF SHE- ALL ARE DECISIONS ARE
NOT YES SCHOOL I MEAN IT'S NOT
AS IS BASED ON PARTLY ADVANCED
SOME AT ONE FIVE THAT HEALTH
HIS WITHOUT THAT AREA AND SO
FAR HAVE COME CHARLIE YEAH AND
HAVE CONTROL THERE'S ABSOLUTELY
NO SPORTS WHATSOEVER WE FOLLOW
THE- THE IDEA AMERICAN HIGH
SCHOOL AND- ATHLETIC
ASSOCIATION GUIDANCE ON THIS ON
HAND AND THERE WILL BE A AND B.
THERE ARE SOME OF THE SPORTS SO
TRACK AND FIELD FOR EXAMPLE.
CALL FROM SOME SWIMMING- ABOUT
NON CONTACT AND LIMITED NUMBER
OF ADULTS AND THEY DO IT
SAFELY- BUT THAT'S THE EXTENT
THAT THE KEY IS EVER GONNA
FOLLOW- THE GUIDELINES AND TO
MAKE SURE THAT A LOT OF THE
EXPERIENCE FOR STUDENTS ARE
THIS IS SACRED HOSPITAL-
INITIALLY SEEING YOU KNOW THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS IS THAT UP AS
DOZENS RACE ENGINE WE HAVE.
FAMILY MEMBERS WHO ARE SERVING
TO TAKE THE KIDS AND TAKE CARE
OF THEIR OF THEIR FAMILIES- SO
THAT THAT SO THAT THEY ARE
PREPARED AND SURROUNDING THIS
ISSUE SO WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE
TO DO THAT- ON THE OTHER PHONE
REAL QUICK COUPLERS US. I
DON'T. QUESTION THAT I WOULD
YOU WOULD YOU HAVE DONE I WOULD
LIKE TO TELL. YOU I MEAN. ON
THE HAND IN THAT YOU OLD ONE
TWO AGO YESTERDAY EITHER HE WE.
ONE NEXT. YEAH YEAH SO I WANT
YOU TO KNOW. HOW MUCH WELL THAT
MEANS ANOTHER DENTAL. LONG. ONE
YOU LEGAL. ALL THE HE OKAY SO
I'LL TAKE FIRST BRIEFLY OUT
HAVE A OF MY OF AN UPDATE CORY
ON THE OF FOR I WAS BY
YESTERDAY OBVIOUSLY NEWS THAT
RON IS BEEN ON JUST FOR SOME
REGION ONE OF THE AT TACKY IN
SAUDI OR STRUCTURE TRYING TO IN
SAUDI ARABIA DISRUPTING SHIP
THROUGH THE USE MINE OR ON
DISRUPTED BEHAVIOR THE USE OF
CYBER. FUNDING ORGANIZATION
ABOUT THROUGH ON THREE.
BALLISTIC MISSILE ATTACKS ON
IRAQ SO IT IS ON ITS IT'S NOT
AS A TO END THAT I RUN IS
CONTINUED WITH THIS. I
UNDERSTAND THAT TODAY THE I AM
A WILL HAVE A BRIEFING YOURSELF
IN THE OF FOR THE THAT TOOK
PLACE YESTERDAY AND SAW ASK YOU
TO TUNE IN FOR THE. FLORIDA OIL
FIELDS THE GOAL IS TO THAT
EIGHTY TERRITORIAL ASIAN FROM
HAVING TO WORLD'S FIND THERE
ARE WE SEE TENS OF MILLIONS OF
IN PASS PER YEAR GO TO THERE
THERE OF WEAPONS SYSTEMS ARE
ACTUALLY TERROR. AND SO BY
PREVENTING FROM OF THE A LITTLE
ARE PRESENT FOR US FOR OF
REVENUE IN ADDITION A LOT THE
OUR PARTNERS IN THE REGION CAN
AFTER CONTROL THE A LITTLE BIT
TO USE THE FUNDS FROM. TO
COGNATE DEFENSE OPERATE TO HELP
THE FUTURE UP IN THE AIR AND
ALSO TO FIND OUT AFTER. TO
REBUILD THEIR CAN. USE DON'T
YOU'RE HAVING IN- OR WITH A
CRUSHING TAKE IN- ARE THERE ANY
BELGIAN YOUR- EVERYTHING WAS
RECORDED. AND YOU JUST KIND OF
COOL- ON TO GET YOUR HE DOESN'T
GIVE A **** A WHAT- HAVE YOU
THEY HAVE OR- CAN YOU LEFT.
YEAH NO NO NO NO WILL BE LEFT.
SO AS A YOUNG YOUR QUESTION IT
WE HAVE THE PURSE AND PROTOCOLS
ARE MORE STAFF MEMBERS. EXCEPT
SYMPTOMS OR- YOU CAN COME TO
SPREADER WORK. ON A MORE TAKE
APPROACH MEASURE TO PROVIDE. OF
QUALIFIED SUBSTITUTES OR
WHATEVER AND MAKE SURE THAT
THE- INSTRUCTOR CHANGED ON THE
RIGHT PROCEDURES WHAT THE LOCAL
MEDICAL OFFICIALS EXAGGERATING
GETS TESTED- FOR STUDENTS IT'S
A SIMILAR PROCEDURE. OR PARENTS
WILL CHECK THE CHILD BEFORE
THEY GO TO SCHOOL IN TERMS OF
TEMPERATURE ANY SYMPTOMS- AND
THEN WE WILL ALL WORK WITH THE
THEIR LOCAL MATTER MEDICAL
FACILITY ON TESTING AND FURTHER
POPCORN. FIVE SERVER UNTIL.
RECOVERY TO COME BACK. IF
CHILD'S OUT FOR A MORNING FORTY
OR SH STUDENTS SUPPORT TEAM
MORE MAKE SURE THAT THERE WILL
ON THE THEIR STUFF AND THEN
PROVIDE TAX. OF FOUR THE
INSURANCE DIVISION THAT THEY
THEIR OF EDUCATE SO THERE'S
MULTIPLE WAYS THAT WE WILL TAKE
CARE OF PLANNED FOR. ALL THE
INEVITABLE- POSITIVE RESULTS
BUT- WE ARE COMFORTABLE IN THAT
CHILD- IT SOUNDS LIKE A CLICHE
NO CHILD LEFT BEHIND BUT
OBVIOUSLY WE TAKE VERY VERY
SERIOUSLY GEORGE FOR STUDENTS
AND WE WILL SURE THAT THEY WILL
TAKE. WE TAKE CARE OF
OBSTRUCTION. OKAY I WAS SET ON
THE PHONES- AND WE'LL GO TO-
ACCORDING TO QUESTION IN YOUR
MIND IS YOUR GREATEST
CHALLENGES QUESTIONS WEDNESDAY
CHILD POPS OUT OF SCHOOL OR A
PARENT WHO'S FEARFUL OF THE-
OLD WELL THAT'S WHY WE SET UP
THE VIRTUAL SCHOOL OPTIONS. SO
THAT THEY CAN BE A PART OF THAT
VIRTUAL SCHOOL. AND ALL
STUDENTS ALL TEACHERS CAN OPT
OUT WITHOUT NOT ALL TEACHERS
STUDENTS CASE BY CASE BASIS SO
PARENTS CAN CONTACT THE
PRINCIPAL AT A LOCAL
SUPERINTENDENT. AND SEE WHAT
AVAILABILITY AND TAKING CARE OF
THE CHILD. SO THERE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THOSE TO GO TO
A VIRTUAL SCHOOL THAT TEACHES
THEM FROM ALL THE TEACHERS OR
EVEN A LONG. THIRTEEN YEAH IT'S
A CAMERA CASE BY CASE BASIS IT
DEPENDS ON THEM WE HAVE WHAT'S
CALLED THE REASONABLE
ACCOMMODATION PROCEDURE WITH-
THE WHOLE PM. ON ENABLE RICHARD
BELL FIVE HUNDRED OR A TEACHERS
HAD PLANNED FOR REASONABLE
ACCOMMODATION BASED ON THAT
WOULD SOLVE THE EQUATION WITH A
PROBLEMATICAL DOCUMENTATION WE
WILL MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE
REASONABLE THE COMPANY TO
INCLUDE PERHAPS INSTRUCTION.
OVER SOCIAL. CIRCLE TOWN GOING
TO TAKE THAT YOU. I GUESS. WE
DON'T HEAR A LOT ABOUT THAT
PROGRAM. WELL OVER. AND
PRESSURES IN THE PROGRAM. WHAT
DOES IT HAVE ANY CONCERNS ABOUT
ITS COST FOR DEVELOPMENT AT
THIS POINT. OTHERS QUICKLY THAT
ONE HE DID HE DID NOT GO DOWN
TO THE B. TWENTY ONE YESTERDAY-
YOU DO TRAVEL PREVIOUSLY- THE
B. TWENTY ONE PROGRAM IS AN
IMPORTANT ASPECT OF OUR NUCLEAR
TRIAD ARE OUR FUTURE BOMBER
FORCES- AND- WE'RE COMMITTED TO
SEEING IT'S DEVELOPMENT. AND
EVENTUAL TESTING A LAUNCH- I
CAN'T REALLY TALK ABOUT NON ANY
SPECIFICS ON THE PROGRAM RIGHT
NOW BUT ON THAT SECOND IMAGES-
TO SEE THAT PROGRAM FOR A- AND-
RIGHT TO DO. YEAH INDIAN UNITED
STATES FOUR THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY STUDENTS OR IN
THE WORLD AND THE VIRTUAL
SCHOOL. IN EUROPE HISTORY
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY
FOUR. AND IN THE PACIFIC IT'S
TWO THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY EIGHT. WHICH EXHIBIT
WHICH IS TEN THOUSAND TWENTY
EIGHT BUT I GROUNDS DETECT
HOUSE OKAY ONE. THESE ARE
SPECIFIC CHALLENGES IN VIRTUAL
LEARNING FRIDAY IN THE PACIFIC
THEATER BECAUSE OF THE US IN
TERMS OF THE TECHNOLOGY OUT. OF
THAT BECOMING A CONTROL FINDS
THOSE BIG NO ACTUALLY THE- IT A
THE CONNECTIVITY IS IT IS BEEN.
DONE WITH DRESS WELL WE HAVE
HOUSE TO ARE THERE ARE GIVEN TO
STUDENTS NEED THEM I HOUSE
SPOTS WE THOUGHT DISTRIBUTED
OVER SEVEN THOUSAND CHROMEBOOKS
RICHARD THE CONNECTIVITY TO THE
VIRTUAL SCHOOL- WE HAVE NOT HAD
CONNECTIVITY ISSUES ON AND OF
COURSE OUR ELDERS IN THE
PACIFIC WITH THE INSTRUCTOR SO.
IT'S ALL GOOD TIME ZONE AND
THEY ARE TALKING TO ONE ANOTHER
SHOW NO WE EVER RUN INTO THAT-
AND WHEN WE DID WE ADDRESSED IT
WITH THE UNIVERSAL HOUSE FIVE.
ALRIGHT. WE'LL MASTELLER MAYBE
SAVE. I THANK YOU JUST BRADY
ACT REFORM AND THE DIFFERENCE
VIRTUAL REMOTE SCHOOLING.
RUSSELL WOULD BE DOWN IN
LOWERCASE. FOR WHICH REGION
MORTARS ON OPTION BECAUSE LOCAL
CONDITIONS AND VIRTUAL THE
DOCTOR PLACES FOR BREAKING
MORTARS AUTHOR BUT HE MARKUP
FOR THAT CORRECT. IT'S YEAH I
THINK YOU HAVE IT IF I COULD GO
JUST A LITTLE BIT FOR ABOUT THE
BROKEN OR THERE WAS A WELL
KNOWN. IS A- SHORT TERM. ANSWER
TO KEEP. STUDENTS AND TEACHERS
TOGETHER WHILE PENNY RETURN FOR
THE WORSE ORDER OF THE NATIONAL
IS A SET CORY. DESIGNED TO BE A
SCHOOL AS A SEMESTER LONG
WITHOUT ELECTIVES ECCENTRIC
SATCHER YEAH I THINK. I THINK
YOU GOT IT. OKAY COME OUT HERE
TO REJECT. THANK YOU MR BREGIER
HAVE SAID THE BECAUSE OF THE
TAXES OF POSITIVE TEST NOW
AVAILABLE. HAS DON'T DO LOOK AT
THE RISK THAT STUDENTS MAY DIE
BY RETURNING TO SCHOOL THERE SO
OUR STUDENTS. ACT INCREASED
RISK OF DYING HELLO JEFF I
THINK THAT WHATEVER IN THE-
THAT THE COVID IS US AS A-
TERRIBLE DIFFICULT DISEASE THAT
WE'RE DEALING WITH- WE'RE
PUTTING IN THE BEST MEASURES
AND POSSIBLY CAN TO MITIGATE
ANY RISKS- THAT INCLUDES- FACE
MASKS AND THAT INCLUDES SOCIAL
DISTANCING HANDWASHING ALL THE
THINGS THAT MR BRADY WENT
THROUGH- WE- AT DEPARTMENT
OFFENSE WE CONTINUE TO. OPERATE
ALL OF OUR EFFORTS AROUND THE
WORLD- THE SCHOOLS IS ONE THING
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
OPERATE WE'RE HERE WE CAN
ALWAYS OTHERS RISK. GIVING
PARENTS- AND TEACHERS THE
OPTION IF THEY- BELIEVE THAT
THAT RISK IS MORE THAN THEY'RE
WILLING TO TAKE ON TO SEEK OUT
ADDITIONAL ALTERNATIVES OTHER
TECH BEHEMOTHS CLASS AS
MAJORITY TALKED ABOUT WE HAVE
ON THE VIRTUAL LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT IT'S AVAILABLE TO
THEM AS WELL- AND SO THAT THIS
IS GONNA BE SOMETHING WELL
WORKING WITH COMMUNITIES
WORKING WITH PARENTS WORKING
WITH TEACHERS. TO REACH US A
SOLUTION THAT'S BEST FOR THEM
AND TO LIMIT THE RISK AS MUCH
AS POSSIBLE. FOR YOU TO ANSWER
ONE OF MORE. YEAH THING THAT
I'M TELLING YOU RIGHT IN BUYING
FOR. HOURS I THANK FAST. TRACK
CHILDREN FROM K. AT. THE END OF
THE MONTH AND I GET LEFT. AND
BIG BROTHER. ACCORDING THAT.
CAN BE BACKED YOUR OLDER
RELATIVES. AND THEN ADDRESS FOR
HE'LL GET ON THAT. FIELD OVER
FINALLY DOES THAT OKAY HI.
INCHES THE ON HIGHER FEEL GIVEN
FACT. ABOUT KEEPING EVERYTHING
THAT OF AFRICA. THIS IS- WE
WORK WITH A LOCAL COMMANDERS
AND ALL MEDICAL EXPERTS AND
THAT IS NOT ON THAT OPTION THAT
THAT APPROACH FIVE OR. FOUR
ASSISTANCE ACCORDING TO CDC.
OKAY ON THE LOCAL QUESTIONS NOT
VERY OVER CENTCOM ON WHAT THE
ACTUAL ROLE IT IS GOING TO BE
IN THE AREA- I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT WE DON'T WORK WITH OUR
PARTNERS IN THE AREA TO
PROTECT- OUR PARTNERS PROTECT
AMERICANS IN THE AREA PROTECT
OUR FORCES- WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
THE RIGHT TO SELF DEFENSE- BUT
OTHER THAN THAT I DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING. SPECIFIC SPORTING.
ACT YEAH AT THANK CONCERNED AND
STRIPES MY QUESTION ON- ON
WHETHER DOES DODEA PROVIDE.
FOOD ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS SUCH
AS REDUCED LUNCHES. AND IF SO
ARE YOU MAKING SURE THAT
CHILDREN WHO ARE. MAKING REMOTE
OR VIRTUAL CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THAT ANYWAY- THANK YOU YES
WE DO WE HAVE- WE PROVIDED OVER
ONE MILLION ON GRAB AND GO
LUNCHES. IN THE SPRING ONE HOUR
SURE ONE MOMENT. ALL AT NO
COST. ON SHIP HER INITIAL THEY
WOULD DRIVE UP TO THE SCHOOL
GET SOMEONE SHOULD DRIVE ON SO
WE'RE KEENLY AWARE OF THE
IMPACT. CHRISTIAN ON A MORE. ON
HIM DID HAVE THAT. GRETCHEN
GOES TO STAB WISH. ON AND WE
WILL CONTINUE TO PROVIDE PROPER
MEALS TO WORK. WITHIN THE FDA
GUIDELINES AND SO WE'RE
PURSUING- THAT. CONTINUATION OF
THE PROGRAM. GRETCHEN CAN BE A
FIRST YOU HAVE ANY ON FRIENDS
PLANNED. ERIC JOHNSON AND THAT
SHOULD FOR TO THE EASTERN
MEDITERRANEAN BECAUSE
PREVENTION OF. BETWEEN THIRTY
AND THAT I AGREE I THANK THEM
FOR THE YOU HAVE ANY FIVE DAYS
AND FOUR WEEKS. ABOUT THE
PEOPLE WHO THAT THE HIGH BACK
SO AND ENABLE. US TO OFFER ON
ON BEIRUT. WE'RE GONNA MORE
ONCE AGAIN TERRIBLE TRACK THAT
NOT HAS TAKE PLACE IN IN THEIR
ROOM WEEK US IS BANNED-
CONTINUE TO ASSIST- THE- ONE
PEOPLE A LOT OF THESE ARE. THE
DEPARTMENT IS SUPPORTING US DVD
TITLED AGENTS FROM GOVERNMENT I
KNOW ON THE ACT NATURE BARS IS
THAT REASONS ONE HOUR A STUDENT
IT TELL COORDINATE RELIEF
EFFORTS SO THE US CONSTANCE
HERE WITH RELEASE OF. INCLUDE
FOOD MEDICAL SUPPLIES- AND- WAR
COULD YOU DO THAT WHETHER IT'S
THROUGH CENTCOM- WE EUROPEAN
COMMAND HAS- SIX USA ID
PURCHASED INTERAGENCY EMERGENCY
HEALTH KITS ONE ANOTHER ONES
THAT POLLUTE THE RAND SIGNED
AND DELIVERED FIVE THAT HAVE
THE ABILITY THAT SUPER HELPFUL
THE HOSPITAL SUPPORT OF SIXTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE FOR THREE
MONTHS SO WE DON'T PROVIDE A
LOT OF RESOURCES IN TERMS
INVESTIGATION ITSELF WILL
CONTINUE HIS EFFORTS OF THE
LEBANESE GOVERNMENT SAYING THEY
WORK TO THE INVESTIGATION- WE
WILL AS I MENTIONED LAST WEEK-
IF PASSED WILL. BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO THEM-
BUT- WE'RE NOT GONNA GET AHEAD
OF THEM REACHING THE CONCLUSION
MAKING A. STATEMENT ABOUT THE
CAUSES OF THE EXPO HI AGAIN AND
FOR AND THEN TURN IN THE
EASTERN THAT OBVIOUSLY
CONCERNED WITH WITH SOME OF END
ARE TAKING PLACE IN THE
MONITORING- FRAN. AND THEY ARE
BOTH INCREDIBLY POOR IN AWHILE.
AND WE RELY TO SEE THE TENSIONS.
LOWERED AND SO WE TO SEE THEM
TO WORK TOGETHER AND OUT OF THE
SCHOOL. THAT ON TO NOT INVOLVE
OF THE NECESSITIES HAVING.
WORSHIP OR HAVING DEPLOY ON.
YEAH WASN'T ROBERTON BARMAN.
ALRIGHT WE'LL GO BACK TO PHONES
WILL. ACCORDING TO BE. THIRD
OKAY ALL RIGHT YEAH YEAH I HAVE
A QUESTION- WE KEEP GOING
THROUGH HERE ONE- KAREN FROM
MILITARY TIMES. HI MY QUESTION
I'M VERY THREE REIGNING THE
CLASS IS PART OF TEACHERS NEED
TO BE RESPONSIBLE FOR SOME OF
THAT AND- THEY- TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY CLASSROOMS ARE MORE
OVER THERE AND I CAN REQUIRE
MORE RESEARCH REGARDING JAIL
GOOD QUESTION YES THEY DO WHEN
WE'VE ALREADY MODIFIED OR
DESTROYED. TRACKS AROUND THE
WORLD TO- COUNT FOR THE
ADDITIONAL CLEANING TO CDC
STANDARDS BUT WE INSIDE THE
CLASSROOM- THE THEIR THEIR ARMS
AND SHE SHOULD WILL BE PROVIDED
THE PROPER CLEANING MATERIALS
BUT THEY'RE NOT- WE'RE
DESIGNING LIKE THE
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIAL TO HAVE
A MINIMAL AMOUNT OF REQUIRED
CLEANING AND BY THAT I'M
TALKING ABOUT THE MINUTE DEALS
WITH THE YOUNGER CHILDREN. BUT
WITH USING THE BLOCKS AWAY
BECAUSE THEY WILL BE AND
USUALLY A BAG OF FOR EACH
CHILD- SO YOU DON'T HAVE THAT
GO PASSING IT DOESN'T REPORT AS
A TEACHER TO TAKE VALUABLE TIME
TO DO THAT SO WE'RE NOT
EXPECTING AN'T OR TEACHERS TO
BE- TO MAKE A STORY OF WORKERS-
WE'RE TAKING A PROPER PLANNING
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT THAT'S-
NOT. THE NOT PART OF THEIR
PROCESS BUT THERE ARE AREAS OF
THE WORLD AND THEY'VE BEEN
INSTRUCTED TO DO THAT I KNOW
THEY WILL GLADLY AREN'T LIMITED
TO- FIVE MONTHS OR- ZERO. I AND
YEAH ACT WHAT IS YOUR WE REGRET
HELLO NEWS REPORTS. ABOUT HIS.
FROM YEAH IS YOUR THE ONES THAT
ARE SPECIFICALLY CLAIMING THAT
COMING OUT. OR TO HANDLE WHICH
WOULD YOU HAVE. I DON'T IN THE
MIDDLE EAST. JAMES OF ANY
CREDIBLE IN INTO THE REPORT YOU
HAVE ANY. VIDEO YET TO AT A
GLANCE TO CHANGE. OF THE
MILITARY ABOUT. OKAY OKAY. AND
YOU MUCH AND THEN THE OF YOUR
COUNCIL THEN YOU KNOW THE TRUMP
ENJOYING A THAN THAT AND ON
EXPORTING WEAPONS WE ARRIVED.
AND THE GOT A COUPLE FAILED AND
IN SO. ONE KIND CHALLENGES THAT
WE YOU THE US RIGHT AND REGION
IF YOU WHAT WILL DO. OF COURSE
AND NEW WEAPONS IN. TO NISHA
RANI AND MISADVENTURE AND THERE
ARE WELL KNOWN US AS THE
LEADING STATES. OF PRODUCT IN
THE CHRONICLE AND WE BELIEVE
THAT THE THAT BEING ON BOARD
I'LL FOR YOU TO OVER TO OVER
YOURS DEPARTMENT FOR. KIND
ABOUT THE ACTUAL THE WHAT TAKE
BUT WE IT IS NOW. IN THE POLICE
THAT ON THE PROBABLY SAME POLL
ON YOUR AT YOUR FIRST AUCTION
CUTTER I DON'T HAVE TO USE ON
AISLE TO SAY LOOK WE'VE WE
EVALUATE PARTNERSHIP RUN OVER
ON A FREE BASIS WEEKS. OUR OF
OUR FOR TO LIFE TO BE GOOD
PARTNERS INTO HOT SPOTS FULLY I
DON'T HAVE A LEADS COMMENTS
WITH THE REAL TO ALEC. AND RE
REPORTS. RIGHT BEFORE YOU
WALKED OUT OF REHAB AND RIGHT
EXACTLY. URGES PROCESS IS THAT-
THAT CHILD WILL BE OTHERS LIKE
IT EITHER OCCURS BOTH IT THE
CURRENT LOCATION TO THE MEDICAL
FACILITY FOR THE CURSE AND ALL
OBVIOUSLY BUT IF IT'S SCHOOL.
AND THEN THE SHE WAS REFERRED
TO A NURSE OF THE NURSE WILL
TAKE APPROPRIATE ACTION TO THE
NGF AND SHOULD BE A POSITIVE
RESULT OF WE WILL CLOSE FOR-
STREET TWO THREE DAYS TO ENSURE
THAT THE SCHOOL POLICE ARE
CHARGED IN THE TRIALS- COLLEGE
TAKEN CARE OF PROPERLY. IF WE
GET PAST THREE DAYS WHERE WE
HAVE TO CLOSE THEN WE WILL GO
INTO MORE REMOTE- I'M SORRY TO
SIX TODAY IF WE GET THREE
DIFFERENT JUNE FIVE- WE WILL
SATISFY SUCCESSOR AND RETURNING
THE CHILDREN IF IT GETS TO THE
SIX DAY THEN WE WILL GO TO A
REMOTE. SETTINGS SO THAT WOULD
BE THE TRIGGER. OKAY PEOPLE ARE
NOT FOR ENFORCEMENT. GRETCHEN
SO I A FEW QUESTIONS OF IS A
NEW THING YOU CAN WHAT EVERTON
ONE BE ABLE I MEAN HEARD HIM OF
THAT ALREADY AND I SECOND YOU
HAVE YOU IN HEARING THE FULL
AND YOU READ THEN THAT YOU A
YOU MAKE AVAILABLE YEAH FAMILY
THOUGH AND ENVELOPE NATIONAL
LEARNING THERE THERE'S THAT
AFTER. EXACTLY HE'S A VERY
EITHER BOLD OUR OR I'M AND
FOUND IN SILENCE SO I'LL CALLED
IN ON THE FIRST ONE WHAT WE ON
RIGHT ONLY THREE THE REGION
HOLIDAYS TO LAY SMALL WORK ON
GETTING OF LIST FOR WHY THAT'S
OUT THERE ON BUT WE'RE NOT
GONNA READ RIGHT NOW BUT JUST
ONE ON THE SECOND ONE THE OF
VIRTUAL SCHOOL HAS AT WITHOUT
OF IT AS A COMPLIMENT TO GET. A
CHOICE AS A AN INFORMED CHOICE
THERE ARE IN ON HER SOME SURE
THE SERVICE OR THEY SHOULD BE
IN COURT AND EMPHASISED ON
OPENING AND BROKEN OR I KNOW
THAT WE ON THE LOCAL SO I'M
LOOKING EVERYTHING WAY EXPAND
CQC'S CHILD FELL CONCERNED
CHILDCARE CENTERS EXCEPT FOR
AND SO WE I AM FROM INDIA FROM
OUR PERSPECTIVE HELLO WE ARE
TRYING TO GET TO AS MANY- NON
REMOTE SCHOOLS. OPEN JUDGE FACE
TO FACE PERSON A PERSON OF THE
VIRTUAL SCHOOL IS PROVIDED AS
AN OPTION FOR THOSE PARENTS WHO
MAKE THAT CONSCIOUS DECISION
THAT'S AT ITS BEST FOR THEIR
FAMILY AND THEIR STUDENTS TO DO
THAT SO I. THOUGHT THAT WOULD
BE A PLUS. AFTER THAT LANKFORD
OKLA THE- INTERTWINING
DISABILITY. ABSOLUTELY AND IN
FACT WE JUST PUT OUT OF FORMER
OR- VIRTUAL WORKFORCE IN THE-
FUTURE IS A VERY- THOROUGH OF
PROCEDURE GUIDE FOR THE TYPES
OF- I DON'T PROVE THEIR
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
PROVIDING INSTRUCTION. WELL
WHAT IS YOUR SHOW RESOURCES
WILL BE PROVIDED US SO THAT WE
MEET THE REQUIREMENTS OF THE
HIGH U. P. SENATE THE SAME TIME
FIVE OH FOUR COMBINATIONS. ON
SO WE HAVE BEEN AGAIN FOR MORE
PRACTICE. SPRING WE ADDRESS-
THE SPECIAL EDUCATION NEEDS OF
OUR FRAGILE CHILDREN VERY WELL
ON IT AND REMEMBER THIS WEEKEND
SO WE'VE GOT THE RIGHT. OF
RESOURCES ALREADY PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND- AND WE'RE
WORKING. WITH EACH STUDENT
INDIVIDUALLY. CAN A LITTLE MORE
THAN ARE YOU HAVE A WHO MAIN
THE R. AND CAN'T REALLY ONE
WELL ARGUED THINKING YOU BIDEN.
THEY ARE HOLD ON HELLO DIGITAL
THIS WELL I'M THANK YOU FOR.
ABSOLUTELY WE'RE TO ABOUT AND
THEN ALLOW ADDITIONAL TIME FOR
THAT SET CHILD FOR FOUR EIGHT
LESSON THOUGHT WE UNDERSTOOD IT
WOULD BE A LONGER TERM WE DON'T
TALK. WHAT WE ALSO REFERRED THE
THAT TO OF VERY AND- OF WEBSITE
TRUMP ONE CAN DO ALL. THE CHILD
WE ALL WOULD AND HEADING EXTRA
FOR PROJECT YOU NEED FOR HR.
COLLEGE IN ANY. TO OUR REMOTE
LEARNING AND IMPROVE IF THEY-
WEREN'T WITHIN A CLASS SCHEDULE
WORK AND SO WE HAVE EXTRA
WORKING THEM AND- SO IT WOULD
BE BASED ON INDIVIDUAL AND
OTHER RISK. WE CAN PUT AN
ENCOURAGE YOUR ALSO SEND THEM
GRETCHEN HEAD ANY OTHER ISSUE
YOU WE CAN PROVIDE THAT. TO TIM.
ALL UP ON THE SHE OUT OF SCHOOL
TO CLEAN THEN BRING IT BACK YES.
WHAT YOUR ANTICIPATION OF FAITH.
I THINK HE OPENING AND SHUTTING
BECAUSE OF CASES LIKE JENNIFER
THREE DAYS AND FOR. AND KID GAY
SEPARATE. AT THE CLOSE OF FOR
ANOTHER TWO DAYS AND- TO GO
INTO CLOSING AND LIKE WHAT'S
THE CRITERIA THAT TO GO FULLY.
FOR SEMESTER LIKE ARE YOU
ANTICIPATING THAT OFTEN DOWN
WHAT TWENTY YOU WE'RE WE'RE
FLEXIBLE WAS BORN OF BEFORE
HELLER'S AND DESIGNING THE
SENATE FROM WOULD BE K. BY CASE
AND- CAMPS AND CIRCUMSTANCE
WHERE. ITS PROBLEM HELLO FOR
EXAMPLE WE HAVE OUR YES. THERE
THERE ON THE LOCAL OF SET THEIR
PROBLEM THEY HAVE AN ANIMAL
CASES OF TIME SO. THAT APPEARS
TO BE ON THE EXCELLENT EXAMPLE
OF WHERE BRICK AND MORTAR WILL
BE. CAN CONTINUE. THE REST IS
FLEXIBILITY AND THE FACT THAT
WE CAN ANTICIPATE WHAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN A LOCAL COMMUNITY AS
IT GETS TO A CERTAIN POINT
RUSSIA I'M NOT PREPARED TO SAY
WHAT THAT POINT IS YET- WILL
BALANCE BETWEEN TAKING CARE. OF
KIDS FOR TO MAKE SURE THEIR
EDUCATION IT'S GOOD AND TAKE
CARE OF READY HAS FOR THEIR
PARENTS TO BE AT WORK. AND
THERE WILL BE A BALANCE AND WE
WILL REACH. AND IT'S PART OF
OUR PLANNING. BUT ON MY- WE
HAVEN'T. WE'RE PREPARED FOR WE
HAVE OVER GOING WITH EX AT THIS
POINT. JOHN PLASTERED YOU THE
NUMBER TROOPS IN WALKER'S IN
THE COMING MONTHS. I DON'T
ANYTHING ELSE FORTY NOW. SO
JUST A ONE US RATE HOW MANY
THANK YOU GUYS FOR QUESTIONING
ON THIS IS OF COURSE IMPORTANT
FOR THE APARTMENT AND THE- OUR-
TO OUR FAMILIES. AND IT'S VERY
THAT THE DEFENSE SHE ACT HAS
YEAH. THREE PLAN WILL ASSURE
WITH YOU GUYS THE SLIDES BUT AS
WELL AS LISTED INSTALLATIONS
ONE OF THE GUYS THAT OUT TO YOU.
AS QUICKLY IN AND- THE WILL
CHANGE THE THERE'S SOMETHING IT
JUST CHANGES. AREAS WAS NAMED.
IN A WEEK DIFFERENCES AND ALL
ALL. THAT BUT THEY YOU GUYS FOR
THIS IS IMPORTANT TO
INFORMATION JINPING. OF
STUDENTS ARE THE NEXT OR SO
WILL STOP. THANK YOU GUYS THANK
VERY MUCH. FOR RIGHT NOW. I
THOUGHT ABOUT THAT FOR NOT
SOCCER THAT. YEAH THAT THAT
PROBLEM. WE CAN. THE PARENT
HOURS. RIGHT IN ORDER RIGHT.
YE